hey there friends today we're going to
learn about air pollution and to start
off we're going back in time to the
small town of donora pennsylvania in
october of 1948.
[Music]
walking into this small industrial town
you can immediately sense that something
is wrong
it's the middle of the day but there's a
thick yellowish smog everywhere
enveloping everything and even blocking
out the sun it's so dark that street
lights are on during the daytime it
stings your eyes and it's hard even
painful to breathe
what we're experiencing is the donora
death fog one of the worst air pollution
disasters in the united states
was an industrial town full of steel
plants and mills which released toxic
emissions such as hydrogen fluoride and
sulfur dioxide when processing steel and
other metals
normally these poisonous gases would
disperse into the atmosphere
but this time there was a temperature
inversion which caused a blanket of warm
air to cover a layer of colder air near
the surface and right over denora
consequently the toxic emissions were
essentially trapped under the warm air
over the course of several days from
october 26th to october 31st these toxic
emissions had accumulated so much that
half of the 14 000 people living in
donora suffered from respiratory
problems and 20 people died
relief only came when the steel mills
were shut down and a rainstorm
alleviated the smog
but following the deadly donora smog the
public began to realize just how
dangerous and life-threatening air
pollution could be and citizens demanded
change donora became a turning point in
u.s history and was the start of the
clean air movement